we turn now to the coronavirus and a new
headline that is getting a lot of
attention a new analysis by the Kaiser
Family Foundation shows 58 of covet
debts in August were people who have at
one point received a vaccine to tell us
what's going on here we're joined by CBS
2's contributor Dr Celine gounder who is
also editor at large for public health
at Kaiser health news doctor good
morning good to see you good to see you
um so let's go through this headline
only 13 percent of Americans age 18 and
older have gotten an updated booster so
will the boosters protect against the
current variants of the covid-19
infection that is going around now and
if someone gets that booster more
importantly will they be protected in
time for year-end Gatherings what we
know is that getting an updated booster
is better than not getting a booster so
it may not be perfect it may not be
perfectly matched against the currently
circulating variants but it is better
than nothing and if you are somebody who
is 50 and over if you're
immunocompromised if you're pregnant it
is especially important that you go out
and you get a booster dose but help me
understand this headline because I've
seen it trending on social media that
people who have received a vaccine but
not necessarily a booster are NASA
coming to the virus what does that mean
well this is something we've been trying
to message since the beginning of
vaccine rollout that eventually when
enough of the population is vaccinated
this is to be expected because so many
people are vaccinated you're going to
have some breakthroughs some
hospitalizations and deaths in that
group but I think the clear message to
give people is currently today if you
have been vaccinated and you've gotten
your updated booster you are 15 1 5 15
times less likely to die than somebody
who is not vaccinated so a booster means
you're up to date so the vaccine
if you just if you just have the initial
vaccine then it no longer is steady in
keeping you
um protected protected and especially
again if you're over 50 if you're
immunocompromised if you're pregnant
your immune system just doesn't respond
as well to the vaccine and so especially
for those groups because you're at
higher risk for progression to severe
disease you really need to go out and
get that booster as soon as possible and
it does take about two weeks for that
booster to really kick in so take that
into account as well and it's it's a
reminder too that we could all use these
reminders of basic things we've learned
during the pandemic the folks just
aren't really up to speed on what about
those there's some folks watching right
now who have covid they may want to see
relatives tomorrow well next week or at
some point what's the advice for
recovery time and is there really
anything you can do to speed that up
before you can see people well there are
medications and I think this is
something that people are forgetting
there are medications an oral pill that
you can be taking for for covid it's
been a little challenging I think for
some people to access that part of that
is doctors unfortunately don't
understand it's not how sick you are now
that's not what determines whether you
should get treated with Pax lobid in
particular but rather are you at
increased risk for progression of severe
disease so again people over 50 people
who have are immunocompromised people
who have underlying medical conditions
those are the people if you have covid
you should get started on treatment
right away and one Avenue that's opened
up that will make it much easier to get
this is CVS now has their pharmacists
prescribing paxilabid so you can go
online to CVS to their website follow
the instructions and you can get pets of
it that way good to know good Ryan Focus
great to see you happy day after
Thanksgiving as well